in maths we come across this constant pi
but where did the symbol come from let's
see
pi is actually the 16th letter of the
greek alphabet but why was the 16th one
picked
let's use google translate we know that
pi is circumference over diameter so in
google translate we shall write such
words which are similar to circumference
let's write perimeter the first letter
of its greek translation is pi
let us type circumference
again the first letter is pi
let's try periphery now again its first
letter is pi
maybe this is the reason why pi has been
given this symbol so if you have a
circle like this whose diameter is one
unit then what will be its circumference
let us know and for more such
interesting concepts do subscribe to our
youtube channel